[Music]
it's gonna be a fun-filled [__] night
you better call the fire trucks we're
going deep tonight
unopened bag to start 1/5 of these
[__] you understand me if you
thought you wanted to watch the church
tonight your [__] night losin
greetings to the church [__] webpage
over on Facebook you [__] I'm
making it happen
[Music]
figure in black that points at me oh
[__]
the devil is showing up tonight if
you're under 18 hang up now this ain't
no [__] horror movie this is life
[__]
we got everything tonight we got
Chocolate Chunk
we got The Devil's [__] dandruff got
blue cookies police I answer there's no
misunderstandings so get ready to go
steal one of grandmas chemo pills and do
a [__] what you need to do you don't
want to miss you want to be a piece of
this tonight [__]
[Music]
you dare enter this house I'm making
this happen tonight [__] so if
you're scared of the dark you still eat
goat cheese
get the [__] off right now cause there
ain't gonna be your type at night I
don't like [__] goat cheese I don't
like goats mud [__] all right you wanna
hang out with goats and go [__] hang
out go over the [__] level I got
goats and whatever the [__] thing
with the eyes of fire
[Music]
oh [__] I started with a bong hit in the
fart let me tell you something you do a
bong hit the fart comes out and some
good [__] reefer right there pre
scope with uncle Joey and his main
Christ killer [__] Johnny Bush aka
mush we ain't [__] around tonight I
got the weed that [__] louis c.k
smoke and out frank and when he touch
that lady's titties so if you smoke this
weed you'll be grabbing somebody's
[__] titties but this showing about
titties it's about love spread the love
[__] give him some helmet juice
because at the end of the day that's all
that [__] matters we're about to get
this party started
we're gonna bust two and a half he's a
piece in about ten [__] red stars
that's how we're doing it tonight
you might as well get the process
started cause they ain't gettin no
better from there
the [__] Irvine improv is sold out
and there's a few tickets left for
Sacramento not to mention we will walk
the junior and uncle Joey live 20 bucks
Sunday the third at the Novo downtown
Monday the observatory in San Diego and
Tuesday the Observatory in Santa Ana we
ain't [__] around this is the
transmission fluid inside [__] Pablo
Escobar's truck left over it's got coke
and others minerals and [__] you see
that we don't [__] around
one down nineteen the gold that's how we
do it here
let the intestines do the [__] work
you follow me I got the intestines of a
savage League I can't these are fresh
fresh fresh right from the [__]
laboratory you know I'm saying oh [__] I
wish you were here live and the food to
[__] lounge put away your money we're
gonna have the bong hit seminar next
year we're gonna have a couple [__]
things going on in please already bar
fit me in make your faces
go go
[Music]
we're at [__] beauty huh we don't
[__] around here we're going deep
tonight
here we go God like that you see that
like a [__] serpent I don't [__]
around here people you wanna [__] around
go to the [__] Starbucks with your
little buddies and go vaporize and talk
about your countries you're going to
visit well going to India in this limbo
who gives a [__] the party's right here
[__] in the Voodoo Lounge or uncle Joey
and you want to take a plane risk
getting blown up by Isis just to tell
your creepy friends and Starbucks I went
to Istanbul who gives a [__] listen yeah
that's great go [__] yourself you and
this time of the year when you get blown
up you come back with a missing leg and
you got a [__] bicycle with two horns
come see me that I'm saying the [__] you
think you're dealing up for Joey live
and in color we're [__] around look
at this you gotta take them like this as
a little faith it's a little brother
package okay oh [__] recite that little
Atlee you got one left over there we're
going deep tonight if I rub this juice
on your fingers on your neck you'll test
positive at UPS you format how the [__]
do I know cuz I know [__] there's
what I do for a living these edibles and
meditate
let us drink him water like President
Trump
nobody says dick dick what's the time
four stars among its what do you think
[Music]
slinging bounce never talking just keeps
walking does magic
[__] you think you're dealing with you
know I'm gonna hit you right between the
eyes tonight if you want to see the
devil you gotta put on Black Sabbath's
first out cuz that's what the real
[__] camp is doing I'm saying is
their first out with a transition from
the band called earth the Black Sabbath
little [__] you think you're dealing we
want to give me a quiz call Jeopardy I
don't [__] around I'll beat that little
Chinese schoolteacher from my house from
Ohio the debt disappear without warning
uncle Joey is here he got a second this
is the bong head of debt this is from
the wall i jus fingernails toenails
fungi dust mushroom dust all the goods
when you want to smoke weed and smoke
from the draw you know that we'd get you
on the draw and after by the year you
got an ounce in there mixed with [__]
staples and lint that should have put
you on another planet you ready to go -
I go wait but you leave with the little
[__] Kevin Spacey short side you try
to drive the boys crazy this is the one
Lee this is the one this is the one that
[__] up my gloom bonus system there
you go that's the one that's the one no
dress look he always like a sack that's
hopefully how you going like a corporal
of [__] they gonna say go that's the
[__] till my boom bonus
[Applause]
there goes one long you understand me
thank God God gives you throw me where
the lung kill is here this is good Club
listen to this you follow me house
cancer gonna live in there hanging out
living it every time cancer comes and I
coughed that all right
[Music]
but you leave Italy Kevin Spacey shorts
on he's only gonna drive the UPS man
crazy I'm saying oh [__] anyway tip-top
Magoo as usual you know how we do it you
sit there going how the [__] do you
people don't [__] around here you wanna
[__] around go [__] around with your
faith in French you want to get down
right here here you go behind the Great
Wall of sleep you follow me
while the Sabbats best [__] out look
at this another [__] container dies
here look at this you know we do it with
a container killers I'm happy you join
me tonight you know I love your
[__] from all my heart without
you [__] I got nothing and for
you fat [__] who keep asking me about
jujitsu and geese I got a deal for you
for the Fuji sports.com right now
tell them the church say it's eh you are
CH I'm gonna give you 10% off and hold
off till Friday I'm gonna drop a bomb on
you [__] on Tuesdays broadcast
for Black Friday 4 G's rash clock
eliminates up fuji they fit me a 6
they sent me an 85-year day and it fits
perfect now I lost the [__] wait
listen
don't hesitate fuji sports.com you've
been in jujitsu and you're in the close
guard and some buddies try to pull you
down I've had guys hanging on me because
I got the back of a [__] twice oh
[__] I've had guys hanging on me and
they can't break the gear I had a key
from Pro it ripped had this other give
him some Mukul limited it ripped Fuji
sports.com that's how I roll [__] sucked
as you follow me ADA is here ADA for
later if I'm saying
who's ready who said stars did you eat
all your animals leave me tell you this
look at that thing you can't even throw
it it stops on my finger is it edible
look at that that's a [__] edible you
follow me right there
oh [__]
youtube.com slash c / joey d is the
place to be pitches are you doing over
there [__] celebrate Hannukah by
yourself
it's out great Hanukkah five episodes a
week and a half early [__] em anyway you
bad [__] youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz is the place to be it's
Thursday night begin your podcast nice
and early Friday morning tip top but go
ready for the weekend by the time you
didn't think you'll stab somebody the
[__] neck how do I know I've been
there you know saying tell them hey
these [__] don't know dick
about dick and for your Spanish people
oh yeah they didn't get my mother lie
big guys alright and feel of Gary's base
here I am well cuz they sing at the moon
wrong color look call it I love your
[__] youtube.com slash
ceaseless Joey Diaz don't show up so by
one twenty bonnets and take one of
grandmas chemo pills trust me you'll be
[__] up